[Music]
and love yourself news Oh why'd you look
too much we could all use a little more
about you yeah
I'm submitted by out of data oh I hope
you didn't use it on this do you guys
think that our data depends if I'm
trying to impress someone I say but I
just said data literally 30 seconds at
night yeah I don't know I say data but
they haven't found Preston was it dad
yeah or according to the data I can tell
you oh yeah yeah according to the data's
it's like come on you don't know what
the [ __ ] you're talking about this is
you guys a data right or maybe like
because you're so confident why are you
saying it they think that they're wrong
and that's why that's a funny oh yeah
like Ashton Cushman I've enjoyed brass
and Cushman Ashton Chrisman he's a great
actor yeah yeah David say uh Stephen
Hawking I sure did that was a great
moment right you slipped me right in
there I was like what am I saying
here are three reasons why you should
reject the idea of a soul mate and just
live your best life hmm
but what if nobody found us on me wait
yeah reject your soul mate so I'm gonna
reject those three points
what if yeah I already felt my so many
wants what about that actually
alternatively I once read something that
said that your soul mate is not exactly
the person that you settle down with but
it's the person that you're supposed to
meet that changes you to prepare you for
the person that you settle down with Wow
way too much think that's way too deep
for me mm-hmm she was like oh God but
they say occasionally event your soul
mate could that is what your soul mate
is but you could also end up marrying
that person too but it's the person that
supposedly came in your life and changed
everything because the person that sets
you up for the better stuff isn't your
soul mate that's called your tester um
yeah I mean that's that cream you put on
the back of your hand and you're like
mmm that's not my tone did you need you
have the tester yeah hey you usually
have a couple testers exactly dude you
don't know your skin tone yet I thought
I liked this one it doesn't look good on
me exactly you understand yeah then you
find out you're wearing the wrong color
for years everyone was like it wasn't
you're coming yeah
you tell me the beginning we all thought
you look really bad for I tell them in
the beginning but you're walking around
with their face one call in your neck a
second color nobody said [ __ ] yeah and
then you change it and they're like oh
you came around so glad and it's like
wow you didn't tell me five years little
things well I tell them I tell them from
the start member Christine oh she got
eyebrows and I'm like what happened try
bus yeah that was kind of a bad mood
bill bro oh we're talking about
relationships okay yeah Oh more they or
they hit you with oh wow I've never seen
you this happy quartz like I just tell
people if they look ugly more like she
really does actually a good thing no
because no it's not you know but then
like on the rare occasion that he does
give you a compliment you're like oh he
beat me so ok bosz is my soul home hot
tea I'm team geo though thank you and I
think I just got [ __ ] I saw it on me
yeah see the dirty feeling somehow on
the girls team I was like I gotta get
out of here people up y'all do I was but
I'm CEO thank you perfect that's great
mm-hmm this is my better half so that's
better okay yeah but see it doesn't feel
as good for her I think now cuz now
she's like you to try to cover yourself
you're saying the opposite to my thing
is I feel safe on team G I'd known that
for so many years now I can see it now
mm-hmm I'm not covering anything up I
could see the I can show you though the
first reason here is because you are
your own soul mates oh my my a single
person
this is when I met somebody seminar and
they say that first thing in the crepe
free coffee and donuts my friends coming
to my friends come in to just just keep
your legs this relationship and
well-being coach that exists
relationship coach she says or they say
that you know foreign to those [ __ ]
everybody on Instagram yeah it's
everybody oh my god
yes they say quote a healthier and more
balanced approach might be to understand
that there are many people you can
connect with but that they might not all
be relationship material because of one
reason or another
we have many chances in life to meet and
connect it's just whether or not we
allow ourselves the opportunity to do so
I agree with that
the words out what does it mean what the
[ __ ] did any of that mean actually I'm
with you no I agree
what does what cuz basically they're
just saying like if you're so hung up on
the idea that there's this one person
for you then you're kind of not paying
attention to the connections that you're
making with actual people that you're
meeting because you're so focused to
those just you know to me that's just
said way better those way better that's
what he means by awards that's how
people argue now yeah you ever noticed
that [ __ ] like in the comments that's
how these [ __ ] losers argument like
that yeah that's their argument babies
bumpkin G jobs a bunch of [ __ ] word
paragraph you can just keep tossing it
his word let's toss they're not big a
word a nice a bigger word you know it's
like do please just leave me alone all
you had to do was say David [ __ ] you
yeah hate to say was [ __ ] yourself David
so you know and then they're like okay
my bad dude all right that's all you how
like you know what to piss me off about
David it's like well in a roundabout way
it's like dude just say just say it just
tell me to go [ __ ] off man like you know
what you're over here and you're
patriarchal structure but I might just
say [ __ ] you Dave yeah and out you're
like cool cuz we read that [ __ ] I don't
know if you like me or don't like that
or you know it's more like there instead
of like just kinda think people should
just see they're like somebody just like
them instead some people are like I want
to change this person with my opinion
here's my opinion and you must we must
conform to my opinion go chase [ __ ] you
change my nutsack [ __ ] like oh you
should take like constructive criticism
for like you know this town the third
and I'm like you know when I grew up
people were not sensitive and that bill
that made me build character because the
whole world wasn't like conform to what
you want it to be and so I'm glad that
people can put up and get out there and
say whatever the [ __ ] they want because
the whole world is not going to cater to
your sensitivity yeah taking the plastic
off your kids and all off your friends
and [ __ ] yeah whenever somebody does
some terrible [ __ ] to you you just built
character and you're not gonna let that
happen you again so like let it be what
it is and see this is the mom that
people need and not the mom where it's
like they caught the kid comes home ones
like I got bully today and then the
parents do it how did that make you feel
let's talk about this you know instead
they're like okay it's gotta go to one
is for school
maybe Crazy's my kid gets bully comes
because I got bullied I was like what
did I tell you about showing magic to
kids those are mine you suck at magic
small volume when you came up to those
kids and you said pick any card you
already knew what was gonna happen
opened yourself up with a can of
whoop-ass is what you do yeah you gotta
have one hand up like this well you
should all right the next reason is
humans cannot be fully captured in one
moment I guess what that means is one is
one quote from this professor dr. he
says professor doctor
yeah the name is Professor dr. Jason
waiting waiting so they said or he says
he was like make sure you get my doctor
title in there so what he said was that
quote one problem with soul mate ideal
is that it can make normal relationship
bumps feel like anxiety inducing red
flags a couple might have a disagreement
a result in hurt feelings but someone
looking for an idealized relationship
then thinks that they have ended up with
the wrong person
true eye group that yeah shouldn't focus
on just having a soulmate and the last
reason here is you're still going to be
your own person
that means it's saying like life doesn't
stop nor should it just because you
found a partner you fell in love with
well it is really wonderful to have a
soulmate to share our lives with there
is much more to to life for us to enjoy
so your life your entire life doesn't
have to revolve around your relationship
you are a whole person
that's very true I think if I though if
I put it like that if I was like masae
60 years old right and just said god
forbid like Muriel passes away I'm gonna
be single for the rest of my life
you don't know that no I want to be I
don't want to start that whole thing
over again like I'd rather if I have to
what if it just happened so naturally
though if it happens naturally that it
is what it is but I still I'm like you
wouldn't actively seek another partner
absolutely [ __ ] you listen listen yeah
we're talking about marriage we're
talking about his girlfriend right now
his girlfriend Geo
[Laughter]
you can't [ __ ] believe we're talking
about his girlfriend right now
sorry he's talking [ __ ] cuz it's not as
white or affion that's not true wasn't
even saying that at all let's don't say
you I'm like man this is so just
beautiful language for new David you 60
years old you wouldn't want to move on
about your girlfriend hey you don't know
what's in the works okay said the work
well I'll put in 20 24 yeah [ __ ]
exactly thank you when I proposed to her
and we get married and we had kids and
everything I think that I would be okay
just being alone for it's not even alone
cuz I have my children I have that I
don't think I need another person else
you don't really have your children
though cuz they have their own lives bro
no they're mine I thought at first that
you meant the way if she were to pass
away that you were like I'll never find
and love it's great but you you just
said you didn't want to go through the
whole process again
yeah I'd say I do believe in the whole
soulmate concept but if that was true
then you know people who have somebody
that they love that gets taken away
tragically they find somebody on oh damn
you made it tragic no but no if it
happens that way you know if they're
just taken away those people are allowed
to love again and they do find somebody
else that they connect with right so
that does happen I'm saying for me
there's a there will be a possibility I
think knowing my personality I would
just be okay being by myself cuz I've
had that relationship oh my god you're
literally the up boy and you're gonna be
the up grandpa yeah the up grandpa I
would and I would just be in that house
with balloons
[Music]